foreign
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm your host
Christina Ellis joined today by my
co-host and good friend Dr John deloney
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five five two two five okay
there's a lot going on in the world this
week a lot of drama we've got spy
balloons we've got UFOs we've got China
we've got money stress inflation and
it's a lot to process if you need a
friend today to just talk to if you've
got personal things going on in your
life and you just need someone to
connect with we are here for you so give
us a call Triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to the phones
first up we have Kathy calling from
Naples Florida hey Kathy welcome to the
show
hi thank you so much
yeah my question is um I moved to uh
Florida about a year ago and kind of
following a dream I'm a registered nurse
63 year old divorcee and I came down
with uh instead of like a 18 000
incentive from the hospital
uh and so I kind of made that as an an
excuse to pay like twenty seven hundred
dollars in rent I figured for a year to
figure out what I'm doing and it turns
out that the year is up and kind of the
incentives are spent
and now I have a choice to make whether
I'm going to
spend half of my paycheck which is the
take on pay about 2700 uh on on rent uh
or purchase a home which I'm trying to
do
but it's um I'm finding that the homes
in the town that I'm in just south side
Naples is uh more than what I sold my
home back in Illinois for
what was this dream you were following
felt like I want to get out of the cold
um you know I'm having to work for at
least a few or several more years and I
decided the traveling will be easier
um and anyway so I find myself here and
um now a year is up and I'm kind of
looking at getting a mortgage if I stay
in the town that I really like or I
could go home which is not really
against uh I'm not totally against that
but um you know I'd be with my family
and friends up there but anyway I'm I'm
just I'm feeling kind of torn well
here's where that question about your
dream is important
if you want to change the weather great
that's that's awesome uh I totally get
that I grew up in Texas and it's a
thousand degrees most of the year and so
I wanted to go to a place where it was
gonna have Seasons or maybe
um you had a divorce and you just took
off because you needed to be away for a
season and that makes sense to you you
want to be around your kids or you saw
them having fun and you thought it'd
make you feel 20 years younger and you
want to get like whatever it is
what I don't want to tell you is you
should go back home and be with your
family or you should stay here I want
you to make decisions that are best for
the plans you have but often when we
start chasing dreams that's why we make
dumb decisions financially we get
ourselves in a mess with if we don't
know why we're chasing this dream does
that make sense
yes it does it certainly does yeah and
Kathy I think there's a lot of Middle
Ground here so you want to stay longer
correct you you're not done with the
dream you want to be there
is that a correct assessment
yeah I you know it's funny because I
feel kind of torn you know I've got I've
got six children and like half are there
and you know anyway it's yeah I feel
kind of torn I guess I haven't really
made that
what if I said I don't who cares about
your kids what do you want to do
I know thank you
um like I I I I'm just like I'm your
friend we're having nachos like I don't
care what your kids are are like are
doing they're busy they got their own
lives what do you want to do do you want
to go back to Chicago if you do you had
a fun year paid for by some Hospital in
Florida and as a good control alt delete
and we're gonna go back to Chicago
awesome or do you want to stay in
Florida and rock it on to the break of
dawn like you get to pick are you gonna
move to Nebraska forget everybody like
what is it that you want to do
yeah I I guess if I would decide for
myself I probably would stay
well then if you stay I think right now
there's kind of like two big buckets
you're seeing it as twenty seven hundred
dollars in rent which is super expensive
or buying a house but I think there's a
pretty big Middle Ground twenty seven
hundred dollars is a lot have you looked
around the area to see what other rent
prices are
yes you know what I did and you know
because I'm kind of stuck on this little
town I'm in I it's um
um yeah I'm pretty much I'm I'm part of
the lowest rent in around here is it
just you it really I think they're super
inflamed yeah is it just you or do you
have a spouse
uh excuse me I mean I know I know it's
not necessarily traditional whenever
you're older but have you considered
maybe even living with a roommate
especially if this is like an adventure
it's a season of life this is not
something that you are for sure you want
to settle into for years to come maybe
you could have somebody else who's in a
similar season you know live with you
for a period are you comfortable with
that
yeah you know what that is that you know
what that's a good idea I you know what
I've been told that but I've not ripped
my head around it but that would make
sense in some kind of indecisive and
that would buy me more time I actually
this uh incentive actually is going to
end a year from now so I'm a year in and
uh so you know anyway the rent money
they gave me is basically gone but I
would have to pay back a little bit if I
left even what are you making as your
nurse job like besides the incentive
I'm sorry would you repeat that what is
your salary outside of this incentive
so do you ever get those things in the
mail
that it's like hey buy one window get
one free we're going to be in your area
or you know come down to Golden Corral
and we gotta buy one get one free you
ever get those kind of couponing things
yeah yeah do you feel like you have to
use them all
yeah do you
like do you like sometimes like do you
feel like you have to go to Golden
Corral and spin that thing or you have
to go get new windows in your house
every time you get one of those things
no no personally not snow okay so I want
you to be really grateful
I mean this this company must really
value you and your skill set you must be
incredible what you do because they
offered you this cool incentive and you
don't have to take it
it doesn't have to be part of your life
if you don't want it you don't have to
you're not beholden to this gift
somebody gave you because suddenly it
becomes really comfortable handcuffs
right
well and I think that there's just right
yeah there's a lot of pressure I think
right now there's kind of like extremes
and I think that can often lead to
indecisiveness because it feels like I
have to go all in on this decision or
all in on that decision but I think
right now you have a lot of options and
whether it's you know getting a roommate
or going back home like see the season
of life as an adventure like you said it
was a dream when you started it and it
still can be a dream but I think if you
start putting that pressure on I have to
buy a house immediately that's when it
can start feeling like kind of stressful
so thanks for the call Kathy we were
cheering for you we'll be right back
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
three things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings
visit blinds.com to save up to 45 off
everything
site-wide go to blinds.com now to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five with debt
payments and now inflation stealing more
and more from your paycheck we know a
lot of you feel like you're drowning and
you're scared to death that you won't
have enough to take care of your family
shouldn't have to live with that kind of
stress but if you want things to change
you need to say I've had it and decide
to try new things with your money that
means it's time to try Financial Peace
University this is our nine lesson
course that'll teach you how to beat
debt and build wealth it's everything
you wish you learned about how to handle
money nearly 10 million people have
taken FPU and they'll tell you that you
don't have to worry about money like you
used to they're in control and you can
be in control too decide you're done
stressing out about money and take
control start Financial Peace University
at ramsesolutions.com
FPU that's ramsesolutions.com FPU
all right John this is an exciting day
it is our first time co-hosting together
is this our first time yeah this is our
first time oh man look at that we sit 10
feet away from each other but it is our
first time on air together that's
awesome it's an exciting day I I can't
think of a more exciting thing this is
so awesome all right next up we have
Roger calling from Bethesda Maryland hey
Roger welcome to the show
hi uh thank you for checking my call I
really appreciate it I've been watching
this show on YouTube and highlighting
had a lot of informative information and
you know trying to fix my life and also
wondering if you guys can help me out in
this situation I'm in yeah so let's
shoot shoot let's hear what's going on
so um I'm about like total 45k in debt
right now um I'm I've already started
saving you know my emergency fund and
all and everything but the thing that's
bothering me right now is with one of my
credit unions um I went ahead and paid
off my car loan with them but with the
same Credit Union I have a debt
consolidation Loan in a credit card that
defaulted the credit card is about 25k
the debt consolidation is about 16k and
what I fear is that they did try to
reach out back before covid but I
haven't heard from them and now I'm
hearing nothing and when I paid off the
car from the credit union I didn't
receive my title so I called the bank
and they told me that I should call the
the the folks that took on the uh the
debt and my question to you guys is is
this something I should be proactive and
reach out because I don't have enough
saved up for this yet and pretty much
you know I'm not ready to negotiate and
I'm worried that could they come after
my car that's my first question for you
guys they can't hold your car they can't
hold your car uh title hostage you paid
that you paid that loan off okay uh you
did you pay the loan off
yeah I paid the loan off in December so
that whatever money I have saving up for
that is what I'm saving up on the side
and I'm just afraid Roger here I started
interrupt I I want you to change you got
to change your the your language here
okay and there's a reason why I'm I'm
adamant about it your credit card didn't
default itself you didn't pay your bills
right correct
what has kept you from working two jobs
three jobs five jobs seven jobs to make
sure that you you signed on a piece of
paper hey if you let me have this money
I'll pay you back
what's keeping you from doing that man
uh nothing really I mean I am working
two jobs I have my day job and then I do
drive for Uber right now
um I I I I I recently just um started my
sobriety I'm about a hundred days into
that awesome fixing my life and I was
fixing my life and you know I went
through a lot years ago and I'm finally
you know faced it and trying to fix it
so I'm working these two jobs it's just
you know a matter of
um I'm afraid because prior to this uh
trying to fix this mess I was sued by
discovered and they also came after me
they actually garnished my check and I
had to put it in bed with them on a deal
where I'm pretty much focusing over a
lot of money too I'm almost on a monthly
basis you know but you know what paying
them down and saving up money how much
do you owe until man
uh I don't have the exact number but I
think it's up around 45 000. okay so
when you feel
this sense of fear take over
it feels like
um
kind of feels like you're drowning right
like everybody wants a piece of you
everybody's calling you but
there's a great power
in sitting down with a pen and a piece
of paper and going through all the
accounts that you owe money to and
writing them all down in order of
smallest to largest
and absolutely it may you may find out
you owe 60 instead of 45 and I'm telling
you you're gonna have more peace knowing
facts knowing the data than just
wondering who's going to hit you next if
you can walk into a room and know those
two guys are gonna hit me that's a
totally then you can you can defend
yourself you can leave you can avoid
those guys or whatever you got to do but
if you just walk into a room and think
anybody can hit me at any time your
body's gonna sound those alarms 24 7
365. so get some real data the second
thing is
and again I'm asking these questions not
as judgments or anything but I want to
inspire you why haven't you gotten in
your car and driven down to the uh
Credit Union and demanded to speak to
somebody not demand like a jerk but like
Demand with respect and dignity like sit
down and talk to somebody and say I'm
over my head I'm nearly sober I know I
made a mess how where how bad is it and
how do we how do we build a plan moving
out
like what's kept you from doing that
so I actually did call the bank and no
no go down go down there in person
okay
yeah because they're just giving me the
phone number of the folks that are
holding the debt and I'm like I really
want to be adamant about fixing this you
need to go talk to somebody and look
them in the eye and say my name is Roger
and I'm back
okay and I've scratched and clawed my
way back from hell and didn't tell you
I'm proud of you 100 days sober is a
huge accomplishment I'm proud of you
absolutely appreciate it yeah that's
huge I think you need to really like
you're saying dig deep and find it feels
like there's fear in there there's a
little bit of intimidation I think
before you said you had discover come
after you and garnish your wages and and
you're a little bit afraid you've kind
of soaked back but we want you to charge
forward charge at them make the people
at the bank start to feel like they're
dreading you come in like bring two
dollars in if that's all you have to pay
that day like show them that you are
showing up and you're not going to deal
with it like you're you are going to
deal with it but you're not going to
deal with their crap so
um I would really get proactive about it
like you said you know you're asking
should I be proactive absolutely what do
you do it for work right now besides you
Uber you see a full-time job
yeah so I I I'm a facilities uh
supervisor so I I mean I'm thankful that
I do make enough to provide for myself I
have you know good fortune and you know
my living conditions and all and I got
cut down and cut back a lot of my
expenses and what I was doing what are
you making what's your salary
so I'm at a total um with my W-2 from
last year it showed us 63. okay
so at 63 are you renting a place you got
an apartment or something
no I'm actually running a room from a
family member oh fantastic so your
living expenses are pretty low huh yeah
they are very low so I've been able to
save up you know the emergency fund uh
and I'm going on like saving up a little
by little to cut it attack this debt but
like I was trying to say when I did try
to talk to the banker like hey both
accounts are already you know to another
credit another creditor or they sold it
off to someone else and I'm like okay
well when when I try to talk to discover
folks they were so adamant about me
paying the right amount and this and
that and I just built it like you guys
are saying it builds up a fear that's
right I don't want to call those people
and like you're saying go into the bank
and talk to them directly I don't know
they're going to direct me to that same
number and say hey okay you just changed
the story a little bit if they've
already sold your loans they've already
sold your loans they need to provide you
with who they sold them to and a contact
info there and listen just think of it
this way like
you do owe them money right so I'm not
going to be mad at somebody calling me
to get my money if they act like a jerk
or treat you less than you can just hang
up the phone and you could say hey I'm
not interested in you being
disrespectful I'll pay you when I can or
when you're ready to work up a plan with
me that's fantastic
um but they are going to come after your
stuff they are going to call you and
call you and call you because they want
to get their money back and I am okay
with that
um what I really don't want you doing
anymore is trying to save and save and
do this and say just start throwing
every extra Penny you have on the debt
throw it all on there get very clear
about what you owe put all of your debts
in order of from smallest to largest and
start knocking them off one by one what
you need is a bunch of little wins my
brother a bunch of little ones pay off
the 35 bucks the 75 loan the 100 bucks
here the 200 credit card start working
your way up man and throw every penny
you have outside of that thousand bucks
on this debt get it done with man
[Music]
thank you
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
I want to talk about something it's a
little bit sensitive I feel like a lot
of people don't want to talk about this
but it's a struggle that kind of crosses
our worlds together are you gonna talk
about how fast I'm aging oh please don't
not on air I'm sensitive
I'll make fun of you in private yeah so
what's up so we've talked a lot you have
suggested especially internally here
with the personalities we should all see
a counselor right and a lot of team
members here talk about counseling so
I finally decided I'm gonna get accounts
you made the call
okay which is great I'm excited about it
but then I asked for a quote
deloni I literally got quoted
165 dollars for a 50-minute counseling
session yeah I
okay
hey I literally right before the show
started I could pull my phone up and
show you right before the phone like
this show started I just
set up another appointment with mine so
yes I'm I'm in that boat with you it's
expensive yeah and and we just did no
spin month I literally spent a hundred
dollars a week on groceries for a family
of four and now I'm gonna spend 165 to
talk to someone that's three dollars a
minute and I know it's good
I hope they're gonna change my life yeah
but we do know mental health is
important and I feel like we're
constantly saying on air get a counselor
take care of your mental health but the
costs that's a real struggle for a lot
of people so yeah and there's this oh
man you're gonna get me in trouble with
this so with everybody so across the
country there are shortages everywhere
so there's calls all the way up in
Washington all the way down to the local
level we need more counselors need more
counselors need more counselors and I
coming from that world that's my
community that's my gang like I agree I
think
um I I called one today I find great
value
and
um anytime it's just basic economics
when there's as much of a scarcity as
there is like in Nashville where you
live it's hard to find somebody that
will take insurance they just go to cash
pay because their books are completely
full with people who can write 150
checks an hour and that's awesome
Dave pays you and I real well 150 bucks
155 bucks that hurts it hurts right it's
a lot of money and so beneath that is a
whole swath of people that could no more
write a check for 150 bucks then they
can write a check for 1500 right yeah
I'm like if it's hurting me like this
this is an issue for a lot of people
that's exactly right so
um so I want to point out I want to do
this carefully and with respect
more people are in counseling right now
that have ever been in professional
Counseling in the history of the world
right and and what I mean by that is a
licensed mental health professional
which is a relatively new thing whether
it's an lmfd or a social worker or
whatever
and the anxiety and depression rates
continue to Skyrocket
and so I want to say I've I go talk to a
counselor to help me navigate problems
when I was doubled over with anxiety I
couldn't I couldn't move and I was
radioactive they like a counselor was
instrumental in getting me from point A
to point B
but what I'm seeing more and more is or
hearing more and more is I've had this
counselor for seven years and I always
stop someone and go why
why are you seeing the same therapist
for seven years without stopping every
week for you see what I'm saying so I
also while I want people to get in line
and go see counselors I also want them
to get a close set of two or three or
four friends they can be super open and
super vulnerable with because we have
professionalized human interaction in
many ways we have a very very lonely
generation I've talked about that all
the time and instead of doing this the
terrifying hard work of going to
ask a group of people like hey you want
to come over or you want to go get
drinks and nachos or whatever we just
call a therapist and we pay we'd rather
pay the 150 bucks than deal with the
discomfort and so I'm challenging folks
to
also seek out human Connection in other
places so when it comes down to like
actually making these payments there's a
couple of options I did my entire
counseling practicum and a with an
extraordinary group that was
specifically designed for low-income
or students or folks who just couldn't
make it work and financially and
also the university Network had multiple
different programs that had clinics for
people who were not students to come in
and it was 10 bucks or 30 bucks or it
was free right and so I want people to
get creative about looking at the local
universities in their area and see if
they've got uh clinics that they have
for the general public right is there
sliding scale with your counselor and
just say hey I know you're the rate on
your brochure is 165 bucks I make nine
dollars an hour many many many
therapists in fact I would say most
um have a sliding scale that would say
okay we'll see you for 45 bucks an hour
or we can do it for 50 bucks an hour or
whatever that looks like and make sure
you're calling your
um insurance company to see if they can
help out with the copay right and then
the other big one is
we're blessed here at Ramsey
we have a program that that Dave the
company will pick up x dot number
dollars per session right for X number
of sessions a year and so ask your
employer do they have any programs for
someone seeking mental health counseling
if you feel safe doing that right not
everybody does but but um yeah that's
huge especially it's a great place to
reach out first responder world so my
husband is retired police and they had
an entire Mental Health Department that
a lot of cops didn't utilize it you know
they're out there seeing death every day
they're seeing all these dramatic
circumstances and ending up having PTSD
and all these different symptoms and yet
still not wanting to go in and see a
counselor that's right and the resource
was free so make sure especially if
you're in that situation where in your
job you're seeing a lot on a daily basis
nurses so many nurses work through coven
and saw Horrors and atrocities and you
know there's cops in the field there's
firefighters like use those resources
that are available that are literally
included as part of your job that's
exactly right and I it's real easy that
your job becomes your entire network
work it becomes your friend Network it
becomes your your work colleague Network
and I was always always recommending
people to get connected with people
outside of your work environment it just
changes the dynamic right you might be a
little bit less honest if this person
next to you might want your job someday
or you might be a little a little uh
uncomfortable to tell your friend who
also has a reporting obligation that
you're struggling with an addiction of
some sort right so that's when you might
want to reach out to a counselor go to a
local group go to a local
um group counseling is another way
that's really so incredible but there's
a lot of options if you want to get
creative the main message I want to pass
along is if you need to get counseling
figure out a way to make it work okay
that may mean that y'all aren't eating
out right or that means that you're not
buying clothes and people often say like
or you're we're not going to sign up for
soccer this this the next few months and
that sounds like the end of times I
promise that your kids will want a
regular to dad a dad that feels healthy
more so than playing a soccer game I
promise you right it's so good figure
out a way to make it happen and talk
about sliding scale be open be up be
vulnerable and then get some guys and
submitted women in your life that you
can be friends with and be vulnerable
with so how do you know if you have the
ability to spend money on a counselor
and you'll say your baby step you know
four through seven like how do you know
that it's time to prioritize well I
would say I would say even if you're in
baby step one yeah like you would not go
to a doctor and get your medicine if you
go see a counselor if you're struggling
with depression struggling with anxiety
go see somebody well I think a lot of
people are Frugal right they're like I
don't want to spend like are my problems
worth 160
okay yes and it's not so much your
problems as much as you're going to
learn some new tools that are going to
affect every relationship you have
including the relationship with yourself
well that's somebody said that the other
day they're like this will Roi like you
being a better person like this money
you're spending on this counseling
session is going to pay off like you
will be able to show up to work better
you will be able to help other people
better because you are well and you'll
show up with your kids better you'll
show up with your spouse better just up
with your with your person your data
you'll show up everywhere in the world
well right and I'll say better as though
you're worse all like you just show up
well you show up in that that elusive
magic word that now feels like a fairy
tale you show up with peace right and so
the the art of counseling the the
counseling relationship what you're
doing is you're practicing being in a
relationship with somebody and as uh
mid-40s guy played Texas High School
Football like I know how to do all the
crush it and kill and drag it yep
I didn't have the skills to sit down and
be in a relationship with somebody and
say I'm not all right I don't I don't I
didn't know how to even do that without
sounding ridiculous to myself a
counselor helped me practice being in a
relationship and that made me a way
better husband makes me a way better dad
makes me a way better work colleague
right yes and I think it's so important
to take the stigma away because I I grew
up with an immigrant mom where it was
like muscle through it you know you're
tough you're in for a while it was like
counseling that's not something you do
and I just like broken people yeah right
and I love that we're talking about it
now and that you're talking about it and
just making it something that's normal
yeah no it's I wouldn't be here without
it and
I don't go every day for seven years
right it's both and right
but make the call figure it out
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five hey if you're
a new listener and you want to dive
deeper into the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for your financial
Journey based on exactly where you are
today that's
ramseysolutions.com get started alright
next we have Jose calling from Long
Beach California
hey Jose welcome to the show
well thanks for having me thanks for
being here how can we help
uh my question is I'm thinking about
paying out or buying out my ex-wife for
my pension I just retired a year and a
half ago and the buyout would be 65 000
cash
okay if I didn't pay her out basically
she'd get a thousand dollars out of my
pension every month do you have 65 000
yes I would write that check today and
be done with that relationship forever
oh okay that's what my brother said and
listen I don't even know if that works
mathematically and I don't care
oh okay like the the longer y'all are
braided together man just it's just more
room for Mass dude all right you know
what that's exactly what I was told but
I said you know what let me look on
YouTube and release the Ramsay and he
has all these different talks about you
know money financial decisions and stuff
like that I said let me call these guys
and see what they can
and listen Jose I'm impulsive and I also
am relational Christina am I wrong
you're not wrong okay all right all
right Christina's infinitely wiser and
more measured human being than I am
um if somebody breaks up with me and
we're done then I'm gonna be completely
done
that's just my way of doing life right
like I'm a I was sitting here about to
math it out and then you said that and
I'm like I'm I'm with you in that vote
because yes maybe the numbers will like
add up in a certain way but if you have
the cash this would be a different
conversation if you didn't have the cash
but if you have the cash like I'd be out
I'm done I might because I did the
number I did the numbers and it shows
like I make up the difference in like
seven
to seven and a half years you know
well and how old are you
52 I just retired about a month and a
half ago so dude that was gonna be mean
man do you miss her Jose do you like
having to pay her every month just to
stay connected well I haven't started
paying her yet that's what I'm saying
like I haven't got my first pension
check yet but that's why I got to do
this like today or tomorrow
I gotta decide dude because once I get
the pension check I can't do you still
do you all still talk do y'all still
communicate
well we have two kids together so it's
like we have to talk okay so have you
broached the idea with well if you if it
is it written into your divorce decree
that this is an option oh
yes basically she has to just sign a
waiver form and it basically eliminates
all their Community rights to the
pension will she sign that
yeah she already sort of pretty much
done I just got to push that button to
send that money it's just hard spending
a lot of money like that as well but bye
Felicia bye bye bye pay it off right now
right now be free be free
well and it's kind of that like pick
your heart like it's gonna be real hard
to send that check every month or allow
that money to go every month for
years or six years from now you're gonna
meet somebody amazing and she's gonna
love the fact you're still paying a
thousand bucks to your ex-wife she's
gonna love it
no that's what I'm trying to find you
know look at all the finance and say
okay I'll I'll get this from my
attention these are my my bills for the
month how much do I have left it's just
like all these numbers all over the
place they're just trying to make the
best decision possible like to me this
is almost entirely a psychological
decision not a math problem I want to be
done with that as as soon as I can
I'm gonna continue to honor her and
treat her with dignity and respect as
the mother of my kids and my kids mom
I'm gonna honor her but I'm gonna move
on with my life I'm gonna write her the
check and I'm gonna be done well and I
think it's like big pain up front right
like it's it's a huge hit up front but
then you don't if you go the other route
it's kind of like a slow burn of
resentment you still have kids together
so it's like you're gonna feel that
thousand dollars missing from your
budget and going man like every month
it's like if I didn't have this
situation if she wasn't you know in my
life right now in this way I wouldn't
have I would have a thousand dollars
back and I think that's gonna breed
resentment you don't want that like you
you're ready to move on y'all you know
you can move on you have the money to do
it so yeah I'm with you Delaney good for
you man all right up next we have
Victoria calling from Phoenix Arizona
hey Victoria welcome to the show
hey how are you hey we're doing well
what's up
so I'm in a little bit of a predicament
um I went ahead and I had 17 000 in
total on a few cards and I wasn't able
to pay it and so I decided to do debt
consolidation oh no yeah
why weren't you able to able to their 17
17 000 dollars
at the time I was a full-time student
and I just moved to Phoenix from Kansas
City and the cost of like my rent was
already fourteen hundred dollars and I
have like medical debt
um I also owe my car my auto loan and I
was just very overwhelmed so I was kind
of like okay how can I get out of this
and so I was like
made an Impulse decision and thought it
would fix things and it made things so
much worse how much total do you have in
debt
um total so on the credit card that I
owed 17 000 I have ten about ten
thousand dollars in medical bills and
then I have I think I only owe about
four thousand dollars left on my auto
loan and then obviously life costs and
then did you consolidate all of this or
or the 17 000 is the consolidation in
the rest or something right so so the
seventeen thousand dollars is the
original amount that I owed I'm now
after the consolidation uh according to
the people that I consulted with I now
only owe a little over
um seven thousand dollars since
September I've paid them
um Seventeen hundred dollars because
that's when this all started so I'm a
little bit lesser than that now do you
have who do you owe the original debt to
um I
I between people so I have Wells Fargo
American Express
um the city cards do you have anything
I'm writing from them about these
settlements or are they that they
started suing you
I just got food that's why I'm calling
so it sounds like you're getting run
around from this debt consolidation
company I would end all relationship
with them immediately and I would call
each one of these cards and say I got
yeah I was young and I got scared I did
something stupid and will you help me I
messed up
I would I would okay I would plead with
them and
um I'm gonna say this with all due
respect is that cool we're friends is
that awesome let's do it be blunt I need
to be honest okay I got two phds working
full-time with a wife and kids all the
way through
like school's hard and I'm not Hey
listen I'm not that smart and I'm not
that hard of a worker so what I'm
telling you is you can figure it out but
I know you got overwhelmed yeah you
learned a good expensive hard lesson
right
you got to go get a job and probably two
and probably three and I think you can
still do that and keep up your school
stuff okay I want you you need a bunch
of little wins right now psychologically
as much as you need some money
yeah
yeah are you working at all right now
what is your income
um I just started at the beginning of
last month and if I'm honest I haven't
calculated it out because I didn't
officially start to like the middle of
January but my guess is probably under
three thousand dollars are you getting
paid hourly
um I make tips and I also get paid
hourly my hourly wages 1068 and then
it's whatever tips I get because I'm a
waitress okay and what did you study you
said you were in school
I studied writing songwriting and
worships
Hey listen listen my degree was in
Humanities we've all been there there's
a light at the end of the tunnel
um you need another job besides
waitressing
okay another full-time job and the
waitress on top of that and then on
Saturdays and Sundays pick up every
shift you possibly can I really want you
to work like a maniac for the next 12 to
24 months and just be free for once and
for all
yeah I would really like to be free that
sounds great I know and there's no hacks
or secrets I'm so sorry I wish there was
like a group of folks who were super
bent on helping people they're not they
just want to take your money
and then you're the one that gets sued
not them
well and it's like as you work and as
you have that money available you do
have more negotiating power right like
if you go out and work like crazy this
weekend you just work 18 hours and you
get a big chunk of cash then you can go
to one of those guys and say hey I've
got this much money will you accept it
to wipe out things like can we be done
now it just gives you a little bit more
power so girl this is that's a lot
that's a lot that's heavy but you can do
this you can get through this it feels
like a mountain now but you'll be out of
it before you know it that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show and the books
we'll be back
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Christina Ellis if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of rampy
solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality
Christina Ellis joined today by fellow
Ramsay personality Dr John deloney and
we're taking your call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five hey if
you like the show please consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend alright let's go to the
phones first up we have Chris calling
from Tampa Florida hey Chris welcome to
the show
thank you for having me thank you for
taking my call thanks for calling
my wife and I are kind of like in a uh
kind of a paralysis
um we paid off about 170 Grand of debt
we're pretty much that's awesome man
thank you
um we've been hammering at this pretty
much since 2017. are y'all still friends
uh yeah even closer wow fantastic
thank you uh so right now
um so I I make uh just under 50 through
uh I'm retired out of the military
um my wife makes about 120
um and then when I was working I just
got cleared medically I got into a car
accident I was Trucking for a little bit
uh making about 85 and I had a drunk
driver hit me on my time off so I just
got medically cleared not too long ago
so we're looking at trying to buy a
house
um we have enough for down payment uh
we're looking at a house that's going to
run about 550 about 26 almost 2 700
square foot house and what's kind of got
us from the paralysis of everything
is basically this
um we can buy down points and get down
to like the low fives
um and it would take about four years uh
for like the 350 a month month payment
um to recuperate that money
um but on the same token with this house
it's going to need a new roof within
about five or ten years uh the pool is
going to need to be redone and the
windows are going to be need to be
redone
our mortgage would be looking at about
three about three thousand uh a month
now with the state of Florida because of
my veteran status I don't have to pay
property taxes so it does help out
tremendously on that end dealing with
the monthly mortgage payment but we're
very scared between the homeowners
insurance kind of going up
the cost of everything
um another company offered me a job
which would bring our income to just
about net 16 a month
um and so it would just kind of be like
food groceries and then just a nanny for
our two children uh throughout the day
my wife does work from home and then
obviously you know working locally
driving around I'd be out of the house
too I just don't know if we should
continue to rent and rent something for
about 2500 and save the money and maybe
save up a whole lot more money to fix
and repair things like that or hold on
let me interrupt you right I can see why
y'all are paralyzed you've got 50 things
going on all at the same time yeah
um
let me start here do you owe anybody any
money
nope zero so you're completely dead free
you don't owe anybody anything we have
one credit card that have a thousand and
it's her company that she works for now
reimburses her for like buying stuff
like printer ink things like that they
give her a stipend every month and it
just gets paid off but that could be
paid off right now if I wanted to
but that's all we have is literally a
thousand dollars on The Chase credit
card why don't you just do a debit card
uh we have a debit card for all that we
so our credit got hit really bad and so
we've been kind of putting things on the
credit card pay it off and then put it
on the credit card pay it off every
single month and that's kind of raised
up our credit um when we were 117 Grand
that was like we were still renting what
kind of debt was that that 170.
uh that was a bachelor's or two
bachelors in the Masters uh truck
payment motorcycle payment and about 35
Grand in credit cards do you know what
my credit score is
zero probably I don't even know I don't
even bother checking it and that's not
because I'm like some kind of fancy rich
or whatever I just don't care
um and the bank when I bought my house a
few years ago I think I had to sign
another form
and show them uh my pay stub like you
know what I mean like so all to say is
like I'm I'm not going to play dance
with those Dance with the Devil just to
to raise my my debt relationship score
up
okay why are you moving I mean why are
you moving are y'all moving just to get
out of somewhere like what's this why do
you want to get to Florida so bad so we
were we were in um up in North Carolina
uh just outside of Raleigh
and moving down the floor is where
families at
um and so we were paying like really
cheap rent and everything else you know
um but we just moved back to Florida
just due to the economy family being
here
um just kind of was tired of the state
um you know my wife got taxed up the
Yang Yang for state income tax okay just
things of that nature okay
um and so we just kind of just got tired
of it how much do you all have in the
down payment
uh we got about 28 grand set aside
on a okay what percentage is that of 550
how much down are you putting
um so it's about five or six percent huh
yeah so if we were to go through with
this so the escrow
um the escrow was six grand and this is
once again we haven't gone through
anything but it would be six grand uh
for this and then the rest would be for
a closing costs I was looking at doing a
debate between like a VA or an FHA
um and that's been another big kind of
poll uh each way this would be our first
time buying a house
I think that's where some of the anxiety
is coming from is that that's not a lot
of money down on a 550 000 house plus
you know this house is going to need
repairs like significant repairs new
roof that's you know that's not a small
you know five thousand dollar repair
that's a major repair so
um if I'm in your shoes I'd be feeling a
little nervous too not because it's not
time to buy a house not because you know
there's anything wrong with the housing
market per se but I would personally be
nervous with having a smaller down
payment knowing that I also am going to
have about you know potentially fifty
thousand dollars in repairs almost
immediately
yeah well
about getting the roof covered and that
was like a big thing on buying it the
reason why we've really been big on this
property is it's a two and a quarter
Acres
um some kind of want chickens we want to
like have a garden and then obviously
land for like you know my kid and all
this here's what I'm most worried about
for you Chris most worried about are you
are you in Florida yet are y'all still
in North Carolina
we're in Florida okay y'all just renting
right now
I'm with my parents and I don't I've
been here for two weeks I don't want to
be here another day
don't blame you
um
oh man
yeah like that's why we're kind of like
all through I'm with it because this
company offered me in my hand at 16 okay
I know I know I don't know but here's
here's what's about to happen
you are
you are dating somebody and she's
wonderful it makes a like she is kind
and she's beautiful all the things and
she is not right for you you have talked
yourself into this property and you are
going to bend over backwards to make it
happen and you're going to end up in a
mess and you're talking from a guy that
waited years to land at the place that I
want to raise my kids on property with
some acres and all that stuff and I
hated every second of it until I finally
got there
I told I'd hold up man I'd go rent a
tiny little place I'd rent a two bedroom
apartment if you got to and save up all
your money put 20 down on this place and
move in with some peace not just
sprinting into this thing just because
ah you're gonna get yourself in a mess
my brother
foreign
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five
all right John I came across an article
on Mental Health you know it's in your
wheelhouse wanted to kind of see what
you thought about this I'd like to just
call out usually when I get surprised on
shows like this George has like some
Tick Tock clip so thank you for being an
adult and bringing an article in oh
great what do you got here yeah this is
a good this is a good one it's called
five ways credit cards can improve your
mental health well I got hemorrhoids
America
it's a real article oh my gosh all right
right what so let's go it says according
to a money and Mental Health Report by
bank rate in partnership with psych
Central just under half of U.S adults
say that money has a negative impact on
their mental well-being that's true the
ability to provide for a household or
keep up with day-to-day expenses can
cause major stress stress pair these
responsibilities with the possibility of
a recession and record high inflation
and it's no surprise that many of us are
feeling the Heat I like this setup
they're like trying to just like make us
all feel warm and fuzzy and like yeah
let's we're all afraid like we're gonna
give you something good okay let me I
just want to tell you like so I for
everybody listening I want you to to to
call this out
anytime you read an article and it's
talking about one organization in
partnership with another
usually that means that somebody is
buying the authority of somebody else to
sell their product it's why it's you'll
see companies
um buy a professorship at a university
so they can do their quote-unquote
research for their r d for their
programs and they put all the negative
findings in a drawer and then they just
published all the all the glorified
stuff right just seeing this
it gets better Preparation H go for it
exactly there are
slaves we can take control of our
finances ah thanks strategic use of
financial tools like credit cards can
allow us to put our money to work for us
with this at our disposal we can
steadily chip away at those money and
mental health woes here are five ways
credit cards can improve your mental
health I just want to say to my friends
at psych Central you all should be
ashamed I don't even know what you are
but if you're under if you're if you are
about helping people you should be
ashamed of yourself bankrites just doing
what bank rate does they're trying to
sell credit and uh I mean you gotta
rattlesnake in a bag I'm not going to be
mad at the rattlesnake for trying to
bite me if I put my hand in there
but a mental health group if that's what
psych Central even is
this is just it's disgusting man yeah
it's gross well okay they got five tips
and even just reading it kind of made me
nauseous I'm like oh my goodness so the
first one is using it to pay down
existing credit card debt so basically
just switching things over taking
advantage of the zero percent APR
basically alleviating
your issue with another temporary
solution so they're lying to you now
they're saying they're paying down
credit card debt but all you're doing is
moving that around yep
and then the second one this one is just
this one's kind of Epic it says plan a
free or heavily discounted vacation
y'all we're we're in we're in stress
we're feeling mental health issues
because of credit card debt so let's go
on vacation
oh man and um and let's hold on uh you
should pick a rewards card that best
aligns with your spending habits and use
your rewards earning to cover costs
so we have record high inflation the
possibility of a recession we're really
feeling Financial stress what you should
do is spend just use the right card and
then go on a vacation
this is madness yeah it I mean and and
we've talked to a lot of people that are
doing their credit card rewards and all
of that and everybody thinks that
they're going to be able to be the
person that uses the rewards they never
go into debt but that's so sad that
we're literally talking to people who
are this article is talking to people
who are stressed out right they're
already in credit card debt they're
frustrated they're feeling inflation
they're feeling all these things and
it's like hey like let's why don't you
try this out well and let me tell you
this like and I've mentioned this on the
show before I used to have a card and I
paid it off every month I never had any
debt on it but I always I put all my
expenses in there and to just get free
flights I did all the time
and I got free flights I really did and
it occurred to me one day
this Airline company's not my friend so
there's got to be something else at play
here
and then the more I dug into it
oh it's that single mom who can't afford
food who's paying for my vacation with
her 32 APR fees
I'm not participating in that nonsense
because it's just squashing people who
are desperate who are struggling you are
hungry whose kids need shoes and they
get this kind of nonsense and then I get
a free flight out of that deal I'm out
of the system I'm gladly going to pay
for my flights
that are not going to be on the back of
somebody who doesn't can't afford to
make the payments does that make sense
absolutely I'm opting out man yeah I
literally just posted that yesterday I
was doing an interview and posted that
that's my same reasoning that it's like
I somebody in order for me to win with
points somebody else is losing that's
right and that's just so sad
um the other points are save on everyday
expenses which they're talking about
like cash back and basically making sure
you spend enough so you get cash back
which is kind of crazy when I was on
with George one day and he was doing the
math on like how much you'd actually
have to spend to get that free flight or
that amazing cash back and it was
ridiculous
um another point is build your credit
course and then the last one is to
navigate the cost of a large purchase
they are suggesting to use credit cards
to navigate large purchases they
basically say that
um they talk about emergency funds it
says our Bankrate survey cites
insufficient emergency savings is the
leading cause of negative impacts on
Mental Health surrounding money whether
prepared or not emergencies happen and
they can be costly a credit card can be
a great tool to have in your Arsenal to
cover you in a pin you don't need an
arsenal
you don't need an Arsenal you're not at
war with your life you just need an
emergency fund which means you need a
couple of years of really really
uncomfortable awful hard work not seeing
your family not seeing your friends not
eating restaurant like it just it sucks
I've been there man you've been like
it's not it's the worst yep and then on
the other side of it man I don't need an
Arsenal I don't I mean and I think
what's so what bothers me so much about
this article is it is it it's talking to
people like they're your friend like the
credit card company is your friend hey
you have a mental health struggle hey
you're feeling down inflation's getting
you we have a solution for you it's like
leading a sheep to the slaughter it's
like that is not the solution that is
like the opposite of what we're trying
to do here it's the opposite of how
we're trying to help people and it just
breaks my heart that there's somebody
who's feeling mental health struggles
right now and they're reading this
article going oh man like maybe that is
the answer and they're now going to be
calling us four year years from now with
seventy thousand dollars in credit card
debt yeah that is a bank rate in
partnership with with psych Central did
their study and uh here we are guys
there you go speak to the mental health
of somebody who feels very fragile right
now and they're overwhelmed with their
finances and they don't have an
emergency fund and they feel frustrated
like what would you tell them if they
read this article right now what would
you tell them to help them go the other
way
um
there oh geez there's so much here
ultimately this
um and I think I can make a pretty
compelling Neuroscience case if you owe
somebody money
your brain is never going to let you
rest because even though your frontal
lobe knows and I don't get all nerdy but
your frontal lobe knows hey that's a
good deal that's zero percent APR it's
no payments for five years whatever it's
it I we can look at a spreadsheet and
call it a good deal
you're amygdala the part of your brain
that's designed to keep you safe is
going to sound the alarms and those
alarms might look like anxiety they
might look like depression they might
look like any number of things because
your brain knows in its core core being
that Toyota Motor Company is deciding
what you do tomorrow Discover card is
deciding what you do tomorrow not you
that you're not safe one little glitch
in The Matrix and you don't have food
because this other company is going to
say I want my money now and you're
paying for last month's rent this month
and you're paying for last month's food
this month
it's just a a nonsensical cycle that we
gotta stop you can't go into more debt
to solve your issues and I'll also say
there are some emerging research that's
really powerful that suggests going
through challenges heading into the
storm that's the way to mental health
healing and most of us can't do that by
ourselves as we talked about earlier
about getting a counselor get somebody
to walk alongside you getting a group of
friends that will walk with you but
avoiding these things and trying to hack
your way to better Financial Health or
better hack your way to better mental
health it's not how it works it's not
how it works you gotta take the long
difficult path and do it with other
people and that's the path to Healing so
good we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five on the line
we have Ryan calling from Portland
Oregon hey Ryan welcome to the show
how you doing thanks for taking my call
thanks for calling how can we help
well I really want to know if I'm making
a smart decision
um I'll kind of give it all to you here
um I just recently paid off a good
portion of all of my consumer all my
credit cards and everything I paid off
29k way to go man 11 months way to go
dude I'm excited about that you should
be um I definitely got government
emergency fund um just the 1K at this
point the only remaining that I have
left is my wife's student loans and
that's sixty thousand dollars you mean
you all see all student loans
what's that yes but all student loans
yes exactly there you go there you go
we'll get it we'll get it y'all student
loans okay
um this is where my dilemma is I really
want to move to Texas and my whole
family does not just me my whole family
wants to move to Texas
and we have saved up about thirty
thousand dollars and we could apply that
30 grand towards the student loans
but the cost of living the schools and
the um job opportunities that my wife
and I could have in Texas is very
intriguing I want to know if that's a
smart decision to move my family to
Texas and spend that 30 grand that I
saved up
or is it smarter to put it to those
student loans and continue staying where
I'm at and that's about a year ago I
talked to Dave and he ended up telling
me to move out I live in a bachelor pad
but that's that's pretty much right now
you live in the bachelor pad with your
wife
no well I did I still do um in the past
yeah I've met my wife living in the same
house and we continue living in the same
house and there's like multiple
roommates
no no just my family okay is the smell
still in your neighborhood yeah that's
what Dave was saying she's gross but a
really bad neighborhood and everything
and a good a good portion of my whole
family just wants to get to Texas and
start something new but I'm just trying
I'm having a hard time if this is a
smart move you're saying your whole
family is that like kids or who are you
talking about my two my two kids in my
life okay so you didn't move out of the
Bachelor Pad you no okay all right let
me let me I want to free you from
something okay your kids don't get a
vote
I know they don't get a vote um the
reasons why I use his opinion I guess is
because he will be starting high school
and I want him to start high school in
the same school like I don't want to
pull him out of school I totally get
that I I I think that but again that's a
decision you're making let's just go
ahead and and pretend that most kids
most of the time want to stay in the
same high school with the same friend
group many want to leave and start over
get a do-over they get whatever but
again he's your kid and he's relying on
Mom and Dad to make the best decision
for their family he can't carry the
weight of should we do this because if
y'all move to Texas and it's a disaster
a 14 year old can't carry that burden so
don't put it on him okay I'm not
grabbing his inputs on whether he likes
likes here or move to Texas okay he
wants he wants Texas too I'm not putting
the pressure on him okay so this thirty
thousand dollars are you wanting to buy
a house in Texas are you just wanting to
keep it in an emergency fund what what
does this have to do with the move
this has to do with the move of getting
from where we are to there um just like
transportation and moving costs and
transportation exactly what's your trade
what do you do
I'm a mechanic okay what's your wife do
and my wife is a I'm a nurse she's an
RNA okay
Christina hopping here and tell me
you're an idiot if I'm in your exact
shoes I grew up I was born and raised in
Texas I spent 40 years there I love it
okay it's where all my family is all of
them okay
if I'm you
like you you've cast too much weight on
Texas
it's this mythical place that's gonna
it's gonna help out all these other
areas and it it actually might some of
the things you're mentioning the schools
the cost of living you get to keep most
of your paycheck because there's no
state income tax all that stuff's
awesome it's gonna be very different
from where you are in Portland
absolutely
if I'm you right now I would take that
thirty thousand dollars minus that my
thousand dollar emergency fund and I
would be paying off my student loans
until an opportunity presented itself
until your wife has a job until you've
got a job and then I would negotiate
with her employer probably more than
yours but maybe not depending on what
certifications you have to help them
have them help you move down
right and make that part of her sign-on
package and cross that bridge when you
get there but right now you're living in
limbo land and you're trying to play
both sides of the fence trying to pay
off debt but also save up some money and
try to pay off debt but also let's move
to Texas
and you see what I'm saying you're just
kind of spinning your wheels really fast
in this in in a muddy field
I agree with you um I guess I missed
this part or left this part out my wife
is applying for the job we're waiting to
see what the offer is I had a job
opportunity we're seeing what that is
okay I would see I don't know if there's
any sign-on bonus I don't know any of
that at this point I just know the money
that I have could get us down there
what's your take-home pay right now
about 150k a year
okay could be slightly higher than that
150 is probably on the lower part of it
but it's a strong 150k it might be as
high as 165. so you you've got almost 30
000 that you can pay off right now that
leaves you with like just over thirty
thousand dollars left to pay with 150
000 could you all have that paid off by
this summer
um no
um I don't think so because Here's my
thought your your kids are in school
right now right like they've got to
finish out the school year ideally it
sounds like your son wants to leave but
you could give yourself a little bit of
Runway and still do the move be debt
free move to Texas with no debt and
still negotiate the package get your
moving costs and just start in a really
great place why couldn't you pay it off
by the summer
um because like what we're doing to keep
saving is we're putting so much money
away if that was the case I don't think
I could come up with an additional 60
000. well it wouldn't be 60 years in the
summer you'd pay about 30 that you have
right now that 29.
but it would take me close to 20
something maybe 25 000 I'm not the exact
deposit on the number to move to Texas I
I think you're making that number up
dude I don't think that's accurate yeah
where'd you get that number the 25
my wife's been doing a lot of homework
and I'm getting that number from her I
don't I don't have all those papers in
front of me but she's definitely put a
lot of effort into coming up with these
numbers I mean having just left moved
from Texas across the country to
Tennessee it's not as quite as a
dramatic a move from Oregon there but um
the move was nowhere near that
it was expensive but it was not that and
um depending on how you negotiate in
your employ her employer should pick
some of that up particularly with how
starved people are for good employees
and I wouldn't just apply to what short
shortage I would not just apply to one
job in Texas if I'm her I'd be applying
all over the place if I'm you I'd be
applying all over the place
because you're going to cast all of your
hopes on one offer from one place and
you have no idea what the Market's
willing to pay
this is true and I think I think if you
resign yourself too like I love the idea
of trying to negotiate the moving costs
and it's like if you've already resigned
that twenty nine thousand dollars to
this is this is going to be moving costs
and I'm not going to try to negotiate
you're just going to spend that money
but it's like if you are hungry and
you're like we have paid those loans off
we don't have the moving cost so we this
has to be part of the compensation
package like you're not you're going to
negotiate that much more aggressively
and it sounds a little bit like
um you feel a little disheartened right
now and I think that like with a little
bit of a mindset shift you could really
go in and Tackle multiple goals you know
rather than just kind of passively doing
it here's what the bummer about moving
to Texas is going to be you're gonna go
with you
and if your marriage isn't great right
now if y'all are if you're exhausted by
life if you're worn out Texas isn't
going to solve that for you it'll put
some more money in your pocket you have
any of those problems do what
I don't think we have any of those
problems I feel like my marriage is
strong and the household I mean I'm not
trying to cast that on you I'm not
saying it is I'm just saying if you're
putting all of this weight on this move
to solve your problem it's not going to
it may make some things infinitely
better
but I want you guys to like like
Christina said your mind shift's got to
shift now before you go
and you all decide man we're gonna pay
all this stuff off we're gonna be debt
free let's let's go yeah you use the
best work Christina just resigned it's
kind of like yeah it just kind of is
what it is it doesn't have to be that
way this could be an awesome adventure
we're gonna like we're gonna make them
pay us to come and we're gonna be all
man shift your mindset here not just
this oh it's gonna be like this I'd pay
those student loans off man well and
it's just it's the difference between
going on and all in we hear Dave say all
the time that personal finding it's
winning with it it's 80 Behavior 20 head
knowledge and it's like you gotta shift
the behavior that's how you win this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
let's face it taxes are so confusing and
if you buy into some of the tax service
ads out there you'll believe that you're
too dumb and you'll never get a grasp on
taxes and you shouldn't even try or
maybe worse they suck you into offers
that won't help you win with money but
we think you're smarter than that and
you deserve the truth so here's a tax
tip today are you ready let's do this a
tax refund
is not a bonus it's not free money that
fell from the sky it's a refund it was
always your money all along you because
you're so kind and lovely and wonderful
you just loaned it to the government
interest free
because they're great with money and you
thought you know what they need more
money so I'm just going to loan them
some of mine and then I'll fill out a
whole bunch of papers and maybe they'll
send it back to me at the end of the
year
come on guys if you get a big tax refund
sure it can be super fun and you can
spend it on stuff you don't need the
smart thing to do if you do get a refund
is to put it on your current baby step
then adjust your paycheck with holding
so this doesn't happen again this year
it's your money that you can use each
month to pay off debt invest or put
towards another goal if you haven't
already make sure you work with a
service you can trust you got
complicated taxes get a Ramsay trusted
tax Pro on your side like one of our
endorsed local providers or national
Partners if you're comfortable filing on
your own Ramsay smart tax is the way to
go and Christina I've used both of these
I did Ramsay tax from my kitchen table a
couple years in a row and then this year
I reached out to uh Ramsey trusted tax
Pro and they've already I I was way late
to the deal on that one I should have
done that a long time ago but both of
these options are amazing right and they
got low upfront pricing with no hidden
fees no agendas we're not bringing you
with low prices and try to send you for
a bunch of stupid credit cards or
whatever go to ramsaysolutions.com tax
to see what's best for your situation
and get started that's
ramseysolutions.com tax
all right today's question of the day
comes from Steve in Rhode Island I may
have missed it but is there a document
of what Christina buys at the grocery
store that feels a little free free as
well as what her family's meal plan is
we would love a copy oh my gosh I love I
love this question
um yes there actually is I posted it on
my Instagram account on January 6. my
Instagram is at I am Christina Ellis and
that's Christina with a K and Delaney
you're probably a little bit confused
about why somebody's asking this just
just to clear up the air America if you
wanna know what's in my grocery bag a
bunch of organic stuff in pounds of
gummy candy that's that's basically my
shopping list a winning diet exactly
exactly so we did the no spend month in
January which we basically you know we
cut out all this discretionary spending
all non-essentials we spent on the four
walls and just tried to save as
aggressively as possible and part of
that was we cut our grocery budget down
to a hundred dollars a week for a family
of four whoa yeah it was pretty intense
uh in December we were not spending a
hundred dollars a week I say that our
budget got pretty fluffy kind of like my
body did after eating all the cookies at
Christmas and we just needed to fine
tune we were like we should not I know
there there's inflation right and it's
crazy but like we should not be spending
this much money on groceries this is
insane so we need to cut back we need to
cut it down and so in doing that I wrote
out a meal plan where um I had other
people on Instagram we did this as a
whole Community which was super exciting
we had hundreds of people doing no spend
and I wrote out exactly what we were
buying to keep it at 100 and I wrote out
recipes because I wanted to show people
that it's realistic and that's literally
what our family followed and it was so
amazing and exciting to do it in
community because we had people who were
like I was spending fifteen hundred
dollars a month on groceries and we
knocked it down to 100 a week like I
never thought I could do that and it was
crazy the overall totals for the month
we had people saving everything from 200
to there were multiple people who saved
over six thousand dollars whoa so it's
just right it's with everything going on
with groceries with all of inflation
it's a good thing every now and then to
just do a tune-up and go you know can we
cut back or an overhaul if you're paying
six thousand dollars right that's not a
tune-up that's a new engine but but it's
been amazing for our family too so we
went really extreme for a month right we
did the hundred dollars for a family
four and what was cool is we actually
wanted to use from our pantry so a lot
of weeks we only spent like 30 or 40
dollars because we were trying to use
what we already had so um just doing
that now we've flexed our budget a bit
we allowed a little bit more and we're
already we're still spending about 125 a
week just because we were so disciplined
for a while that now it's like I don't
really want to go back to spending all
that money like why why is it needed I'd
rather go on vacation or save for a
house and do these different money goals
that we have versus just literally
eating eating our food like just eating
our money away like what's the point of
that so yeah I just encourage everybody
who's feeling stressed out about grocery
costs like there are ways to really
really cut back and I posted it January
6th on my Instagram hopefully can give
you some tips and advice on you know
ways to do it and they're not going to
be the fanciest meals like I'm I'm no
chef and I don't love cooking I
basically was like I want meals that
literally in the next like four or five
years I could teach my four-year-old how
to make yeah I don't want it to be fancy
and so can I tell you the the derivative
benefits the downstream benefits
your kids are participating in cooking
you all get to spend an extra 30 or 45
minutes or an hour right so easy just to
say hey kids get out of here go watch
something while I do this it's my but if
you bring them along then suddenly you
have this this connection time together
they're learning how to measure stuff
like so the learning benefits are
forever we get to learn lots of patience
right yes and then I'll tell you I've
got a 12 year old now and the other
night he came in and said hey do you
guys mind if I make dinner and we were
oh my wife and I were like yeah like we
won that is my dream that was literally
my dream but my wife has been bringing
our kids along all the way like and
teaching them Math and how it all works
and all but now
um it's it's fantastic so I love what
you're doing and you hit on something
that was a I I wish I learned this 20
years before when my wife and I when we
sold our house and moved into a
residence hall to pay off that
that was part of the story part of it we
paid off that part of it I was so
anxious I couldn't breathe because how
much money we owed
and I was on a trajectory you're
supposed to get a new house and a bigger
house and every time you get promoted
you're supposed to get another big house
and every time one kid grows half of an
inch you need to get more room for
everybody right all that and then we
moved into a residence hall a tiny
little apartment tiny tiny as a dorm
right
we will never it will completely reshape
the way we will own homes in the size of
the home we'll live in moving forward
not that owning a big home is is bad or
anything like that it's just we realized
oh we actually enjoy living together
where we're all we have to make do and
we have to love and we have to say I'm
sorry we got to say excuse me and it
just reshaped our entire trajectory of
how we're going to buy houses because we
just hit the pendulum all the way over
here and it's kind of like what you guys
experienced with your meals we just went
caustic for one month
and then we realize we can do this and
not only can we do this we kind of like
a lot of this right and it shaped how
y'all are gonna do food moving forward
that's so good I think it's important
for all of us to stop every now and then
and go why are we spending this way I
had the thought that like Amazon kind of
came out of nowhere on us right like we
went from when you wanted something you
had to go to the store to buy it to okay
there's this Amazon Prime I'm gonna
order every now and then to all of a
sudden there are packages on your
doorstep every single day and it's like
that wasn't a conscious decision I
didn't just suddenly become an
amazonaholic I just like fell into it
and even just stopping for a month and
going like I I can walk in a store still
like I don't need to buy something every
single time I it crosses my mind like I
can wait and even with grocery stores I
saw a study recently where it's like
back in the 50s there were like 3 000
options of things you can buy and now
they're like 40 000 options in our
brains I mean you talked about handle it
man it's too much Choice yeah so much
choice so just cutting back and cutting
down and going like I need I need to
have things be a little bit more simple
for a while I need to like regroup and
especially with everything changing so
fast in our culture and inflation and
all these things just taking time to go
hello okay and with what you said with
the kids
um
our kids actually felt it there my son's
four years old and like that was a big
thing for me even like pausing to go
what am I teaching my kids about
consumerism like he now knows that like
when we want something we buy it on
Amazon and do I want him to know that
yeah so just taking the time to be
intentional with your finances pausing
every now and then and saying you know
do I really need to spend that much on
groceries do I really need to buy on
Amazon every time it crosses my mind
like what am I doing with my money how
do I want to live my life and what is my
legacy all right that puts this hour of
the Ramsey Show in the books thanks to
all the guys in the booth into my
co-host John will be back soon
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsey show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm your host Ramsay
personality Christina Ellis joined by my
co-host Ramsay personality and good
friend Dr John deloney we're taking your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five first up we've got
Christina calling from Salem Oregon hey
Christina welcome to the show
hey thank you guys for having me hey
thanks for calling how can we help
hey um my husband and I are on baby step
two currently and we have had the cause
for about two years now and just started
paying back Deb again but we're kind of
like feeling a lack of motivation here
just need some tips to kind of like kick
back into gear gazelle intense again
tell us about the pause what happened
um so I had a baby last October or
October 2021
um who was still born
and I'm so sorry
yeah so
um we initially thought we could just go
straight back and start paying off the
you know a couple of months after but we
decided to try for a baby again
um so I currently have a four month old
now who was also born October of 2022.
um and I just started work back again
now so we kind of like have just started
after that whole like emotional roller
coaster kind of started getting back
into gear again cool yeah did you ever
spend some time
just
being sad just grieving
[Music]
um I feel like a little bit but getting
pregnant pretty quickly after losing our
first I kind of just put it all yeah on
hold what was your what was your first
name
um Georgia Georgia beautiful beautiful
my niece is named Georgia it's beautiful
um
here's the thing about grief it will
it'll catch up with you
and it demands that you honor it and
this that feeling of lack of motivation
another word is apathy another word is
like your body's just kind of bringing
everything down there's not a lot of
color like why are we doing this and
that's often
it's often a tree that grows out of on
unacknowledged Grief
and sometimes that can be as simple as
you and your husband right in Georgia a
letter
tell her how much you miss her tell her
about the the new brother or sister that
she's never going to get to meet and
that you're sad and you think about her
um and it could be a small ceremony that
y'all have a year later or two years
later or it can be as as you go see a
counselor and do some some real trauma
healing which you just experienced the
last 18 months of your life is really
heavy right
yeah and then probably the fear you felt
rattling your body as you were getting
closer to your due date with your the
baby you're holding right now that's
scary time wasn't it
yeah yeah for sure so your body's
wearing all this stuff and then you you
look at it you're like all right let's
get gazelle intense and it's like how
about you leave because we're not
getting gazelle nothing we're sitting
right here on the couch you see what I'm
saying yeah it's a lot it's a lot y'all
been through hell and back and sometimes
it's important just to stop and
acknowledge it
Tina do you have a counselor
currently
um we listened to John's show a lot oh
that's not always helpful right
um I would I would recommend especially
being in this season of being postpartum
having all this grief and Trauma walking
through that with someone because
there's just naturally for for any
mother who's just had a baby there's a
lot of hormones there's a lot of things
happening and then you actually have a
really huge trauma to sort through so I
would want to do that with a
professional who who can really speak to
um where you are now in just the past
the past two years that's a lot
so I'm gonna I'm gonna let's take that
trauma and I'm gonna move it over just a
little bit we're not going to knock it
off the table I'm just gonna move it
over just a little bit okay
when somebody tells me they don't feel
motivated
and they have but they have some goals
they want to reach what I want to
communicate to everybody listening is
that motivation is a fleeting mistress
she comes and goes and comes and goes
and if I only worked out in the morning
when I felt like it I would not be very
healthy okay so I don't rely on
motivation to do much of anything
I'm not always motivated to be a kind
husband but I'm still going to be kind
and I'm not always motivated to go the
other night when I was I forgot I ran by
the store to get something for
Valentine's I had a wild like I'm not
motivated but I'm still going to do it
because it's right and so when you and
your husband decide hey we're getting
back on this wagon we're going for it
and I think I think now's a great time
you all need some little wins together I
think waiting for motivation it isn't
the right path I think making some
choices that we're going to be
disciplined whether we feel it or not
we're going to live like this we're
going to follow these baby steps to the
letter we're not going to deviate off
them at all you're gonna you're gonna
wake up in two or three months from a
fog and you're gonna realize you've made
some serious progress and then progress
begets motivation it gets exciting again
you realize you're on adventure and
suddenly you get that extra extra gas
that you didn't even know was in the
tank how does that sound
that sounds pretty good sounds like what
we're gonna have to do how much debt do
you guys have
um when we started we had 102 we started
in April of 2020 right after covet
basically started
um and we paid off about 50 000 in a
year Wow Wow way to go so you all know
gazelle intense you all know it yeah we
were we were really scorched Earth
um and then throughout pregnancy and all
that stuff we kind of paid off wall
chunks here and there when we weren't
saving for
uh they being basically so now we're at
43 000 I think okay and what's your
income
um last year I believe it was 90. okay I
feel so encouraged that you've done this
before this is not new to you you're not
at the very bottom of the mountain and I
I think right now it feels like you're
just stuck in a valley and it's like I
think the more maybe you have a vision
session with your husband you kind of
map out you know how long you think this
is going to take alongside getting
counseling alongside
um doing all these steps but but you
know having a Clear Vision I think this
season just feels like the trenches and
I think if you see like in a year to a
year and a half we're going to be
totally out of this and and by getting
out of this debt I'm going to feel more
freedom to spend more time with my baby
maybe you have a career like whatever it
is it's like if there's a vision at the
end of it I think you'll feel like that
naturally also produces some motivation
that's right so here's what we're gonna
do we're going to send you
um Financial Peace University the the
updated version and it's got all all new
videos we re-shot them all they even let
me and George do one like so we're gonna
send it to you and I know y'all probably
already been through it but I want you
all to get re-energized again okay so I
want you and your husband to go through
them again watch them again
get that feeling back you all have been
scorched Earth before you did it and you
did 50 000 that time you didn't even
have that far to go this time you got 43
and then you you're holding this
beautiful y as to why we're gonna do
this and you're gonna look up in 18
months and this whole thing's gonna be
over okay I'm so proud of you man um
that's so please please take care of
yourself too you got is that a promise
awesome thank you so so much for the
call we'll be right back this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five up next we
have McKenzie calling from Chattanooga
Tennessee hey McKenzie welcome to the
show
hey y'all how are y'all doing today
we're doing well how can we help
okay so I'm gonna be graduating in
December with a degree in Business
Administration with a major in
management
um I have completely put myself through
school but have accumulated about 1 500
of educational debt but that should be
completely paid off in the summer
um all that said I'm pretty confident in
my GPA and standing that I'm going to
get accepted into MBA schools so I have
kind of like two questions in one do you
think it would be wise to pursue this
higher education and do you think it's
worth it and also take out twenty to
twenty five thousand dollars if I'm debt
free how old are you 21.
I'll let Christina answer this like
philosophically I'll tell you
um one of the last universities I worked
for actually moved the MBA program you
actually had to leave school and go work
in the work world for a couple of years
before you came back because a lot of
these NBA theories and economic ideals
make no sense I mean you can pass the
test out of a textbook but there's no
real world application
so I would ask you why in the world
would you like why do you feel like you
need to get an MBA right now at 21
instead of getting out there in the
business world and cutting your teeth
and seeing how this whole thing actually
works in real life
well I I'm working right now in a office
and I really enjoy it but also I think
more so just the credentials of it and a
Resume Builder uh you know it's kind of
been pushed on me to go to MBA school
from like you know professors so you
know it's just something I thought I
needed to pursue and I would tell you
professors they all went and did that
and they went and got their phds and
they came back and so that's their track
and I and I mean I've got a bunch of
graduate degrees too what I'm telling
you is you you absolutely are not in a
place where I can if I can fathom you
needing that credential at this moment
if I'm hiring and I've hired I can't
count how many people have hired my
career I don't even know a lot I would
man I would much rather hire a 28 year
old with a ton of experience than a 22
year old with an MBA
okay okay I've seen that a lot and I'm
curious okay so you said it's twenty
thousand dollars is that a year or if
the whole program that's for the whole
program it's completely online and like
I said I would be like working
simultaneously while going to school so
I would do that like at night so is that
is that twenty thousand dollars like is
that what you factored after your income
or is that like total cost of the
program and you're gonna have additional
income
um I that is just the complete cost of
the program itself um that's not
factoring in what I'll make after
graduation or anything like that and how
long is this program
about a year and a half she's like an
Executive MBA I
so I'm just I'm wondering why can't you
cash flow this
um well you know I have completely
worked to put myself through school so I
don't have like tons of savings built up
right uh so I you know every time it's
time to pay my tuition that takes the
savings or something you know so I
haven't really built up a savings for it
so and I also know myself and it would
tough be tough for me to go back to
school once I've stopped so right okay
but but okay so 20. I don't buy that
you're a gangster dude you paid for your
whole you scratched the plug your whole
way through this
here's what I think I think you really
feel insecure about yourself in the work
world and you feel like this is gonna be
like a cape of some sort or a shield of
some sort against that insecurity when
I'm here to promise you is it's going to
elevate it
it will make it exponential
okay but I'm also thinking okay so if
it's 21 000 for the whole program the
program is a year and a half that's
about seven thousand a semester is that
correct
I would think so yes ma'am I think you
can make seven thousand dollars a
semester especially if you're out
getting experience if you're working you
said this is a nighttime program so you
can work full time yes as soon as I
graduate in December I'll go full time
and I would probably start the program
that same the following semester well
it's like I know that you have been
hustling to graduate with you know a
small amount of debt you know you're
gonna be able to pay it off by the
summer you're probably feeling a bit
tired and I think you kind of have two
directions right now you can go get a
job like John said and and just start in
the real world and then get your MBA in
the future or I mean we're not talking
about forty thousand dollars a semester
we're talking about seven thousand
dollars and if you're getting a you know
the average paying job after graduation
like you should if you still live like a
college student be able to pay for this
as you go
I didn't think about that that's huh is
this a private school like like don't
give me the name of the University but
is this a reputable program I've never
heard of an MBA an Executive MBA priced
at twenty five thousand dollars
um
I would not say it's a very well-known
School
a well-known MBA program it's brand new
I would is it even accredited
yes it is I'm just telling you oh man
I'm gonna get myself I
go there do it yes I mean you could you
could definitely pay for this Christine
is right
if you're gonna man I'm gonna get myself
in all kind of trouble with everybody if
you're gonna get an MBA I would rather
see you have a bunch of work experience
I have somebody at your job come in and
tap you on the shoulder and say we're
going to pay for this thing and we want
you to go to Yale or we want you to go
to Duke or we want you to go to UT
Knoxville I want you to go to a really
reputable program we're going to help
you pay on this or they come and say you
are leadership material and the only
path forward for you here is an MBA
here's an opportunity and by that time
you're making enough money that you can
just cash for this thing and it's going
to be uncomfortable for a year but
you're gonna make it work
it just I I can't wrap my head around to
where it makes sense for you right now
that's good it feels like it's a little
bit you know a check mark like you've
been told by your professors that you
need this check mark in order to be more
successful and I just don't know right
and I'll tell you this go to grad school
don't and this is for everybody
listening don't go to grad school for a
check mark go to grad school to learn
something that is going to help you and
whether it's taking care of people
whether it is learning a trade whether
you're going to like you know be a nurse
practitioner and you're going back to
your Masters whatever or there's a
direct Roi on it go back to learn
something don't go in it to just get a
check mark man because the the it just
doesn't it doesn't pay off for itself in
any anyways and I'm not even somebody
who's in all like every degree has to
Roi I'm not even that guy I'm I'm
more philosophical but I love higher ed
but man it won't even pay off in your
soul you won't walk away thinking I
learned something you'll think I worked
I gave you 25 Grand you gave me a
certificate and we high-fived and then
we moved all their lives and it's just
not it's not the exchange that you want
I'm with you on that I'm with you on
that how does that feel to you
I did it I really do and honestly I it
would be a really big stress just to go
straight from college to grad school
so I enjoy my job I'm actually loving my
job right now so that kind of gives me a
little bit of a relief to think about it
you know I do have time you know you got
so much time hey you know what I want
you to practice for the next next six
months rest you haven't done that in
four or five or six or seven years
what if you just went to work and worked
really really hard and you read books
and you hung out with people and you
what if you did that
that would be amazing
I love the joy in your voice and this is
coming from you know a former dean of
higher education this is somebody who's
been in the education world and so it's
like we give you that permission and
you've got two people with graduate
degrees we've both been there okay and
we're both telling you just take a break
for a minute
I think you are going to get a graduate
degree one day and I'm going to cheer
you on I want you to send us a
graduation photo when you walk across at
that stage I think I think that's in
your future I just doesn't I can't make
it make sense right now if you're my
sister or you're my close friend or
you're a daughter of one of my buddies I
would be telling you this exact same
thing
Mackenzie go forth in peace rest for
sure that you will be you will be fine
without the check mark and I want oh
hold on before we I I wanna everybody
I'm always telling 20 year olds like
don't rest that's your that's your
season to grind like crazy yes and also
I I know I'm speaking out both sides of
my mouth but she I was reading between
the lines here this is a young woman
who's clawed and scratched and worked
like crazy to not owe any debt and she
has figured out a way to double major
get out of school she got herself a job
and I want her to Exhale for a minute
because I wanted to also learn how to be
at peace because I've got there's too
many CEOs out there that know one they
know one uh speed and that's a thousand
miles an hour and they're they're
falling over dead right and they're
burning their teams out and so I want
people who know how to work really hard
and
who know how to rest well too we need
both of those things in the Work Work
World right now that's so good we'll be
right back this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five next up we
have Caleb calling from Mobile Alabama
hey Caleb welcome to the show
hey guys how's it going hey we're doing
well how are you
doing great doing great how can we help
okay so I had a bit of a
like question just thinking through
um and trying to self-assess a problem
that I've seen in myself and I kind of
wanted y'all's input on it let's go all
right so I've worked three different
jobs I'm 23 years old I worked a small
job out of high school for a year and
then I worked three years for a tech
company and now I'm currently working
for a construction company that I worked
at for about a year and a half now
in all of these different positions I
found myself at different points through
the job I'm really excited when I start
working for the new company but then at
some point along the path of that
employment whether it be something that
happens with the job or just the amount
of workload that I have I start to feel
resentment toward my boss and
feel like I'm not getting valued or paid
enough and there's different things and
different components of that with each
of the different jobs that I've worked
I'm kind of just trying to self-assess
is that a problem that is with me that
I'm seeing this you know through every
single job that I've had I'm finding
that I have this these same feelings
toward my employer and I'm trying to
like is this something that I need to
fix or is this actually something that's
valid and Justified I just want to pause
real quick and say at 23 years old the
fact that you have stopped and said
there are all these issues and I'm going
to stop and self-assess I'm really proud
of you Caleb because a lot of people
your age would be just projecting out
it's my boss's fault and they would just
be pointing fingers and not even stop to
take a minute so just the fact that you
picked up the phone and you called I'm
really proud of that yeah good for you
man so
just track the pattern in your own life
did this happen with um your professors
was it always a professor's fault that
they changed the deadline on you and you
got to be because you got screwed in the
Umpire man if they just called the game
right is that the kind of the story of
your life
I think so I've never gone to college so
that that could be the story um along
the lines with just like different areas
that
of my life that I've worked with that um
is life just constantly coming to get
you
honestly no I'm very excited about life
and like I'm actually currently pursuing
like um training in another
um another course to take another job
and Tech again
um so I don't think I have like a life
solids out to get any kind of mentality
okay everyone does to some extent well
that's that's fantastic that gives me
some great data to work with
um
here's what I had to wrestle with in
Christina hopping here like Caleb I I
very very similar in fact I had a good
Mentor a friend of mine sit me down
after like my third or fourth job and I
was job hopping every couple years and
here was here was my narrative I would
start the job I would do really well on
it I would have some issues like I
always do
and because I wasn't settled inside
myself
I didn't have a I didn't have a good
sense of purpose I didn't really know
why I was doing this job other than a
paycheck or I wanted people to think I
was special I was waiting for my dad to
call and tell me how proud of him was
for me whatever the thing I was waiting
for
it never came that's just not how life
works and
um I then started finding people to
blame or as brene Brown says like
whatever you go looking for in the world
you're sure to find I started seeking
out places where I was getting screwed
where it could have been like this they
never even asked my opinion forget the
40 other times they asked my opinion
that day they didn't ask me on that one
and that's bull crap I'm gonna go find
it where they you see what I'm saying so
I went looking for it but all of that
was me trying to place my self-esteem at
the foot of my job and that's not a
workplace's job to prop me up does that
make sense
that makes very very good sense and I
think you hit the nail on the head that
to the reason I'm so excited when I
start this new job because I'm like it's
this new family of people that I get to
work with and I'm really excited that
you know I get the skills that I bring
to the table and then those feelings
just slowly Lane as I work at the
company and just you know it doesn't
fulfill me like I thought it was going
to where it did in the beginning so
Caleb you left you left high school and
you didn't go to college correct
that's correct what was your vision when
you left High School like what was the
decision process when you went to get
that first job like what kind of thought
went into it
so I worked in Tech I kind of ran a
small business on my own I um did live
Sound audio engineering so not what not
what did you do but like how did you
make the decision to to get that
specific job
okay yeah so um I was I made the
decision based on it was a non-profit
Christian Ministry that I was working
for and
um just they offered me a job directly
and I went directly out of high school
into that Tech position and that's why
I'm kind of I'm kind of wondering and
getting at is like is this
kind of like a feeling of confusion of
like you're not really landing at like
the career that you want that you don't
really have a vision for where you want
to go like where do you want to be in 10
years in your career what do you what is
what is you know 33 year old Caleb doing
for sure for sure so I believe I've
identified that I love Tech I love the
three years that I worked for that
company and I'm currently trained to go
into cyber security and information
technology
um I'm taking courses and stuff like
that but that is kind of my passion I
have a real passion for that
um just with my life circumstances
that's why I left the job that I was at
and it was a bad environment as well so
so I want you to do the the next layer
which I think is harder okay so you've
identified you have a passion for
um cyber security
this is John deloney's opinion nobody
else is at Ramsey Solutions okay I think
following your passion can sometimes be
awful advice because I'm real passionate
about things I'm good at and I'm really
good at things that I practice and for
most of us especially when we're in our
teens and 20s we practice things that
were made to practice
and when we keep jumping job to job to
job looking for a feeling looking to
feel passionate about it we're never
gonna get there because we're never
going to be super good at the thing
because we're always moving around and
we don't just put in that awful four
five seven nine years of grindy work
becoming really good at this trade
whatever if the trade is cyber security
the trade is being a police officer the
trade is whatever you wake up and you're
like I'm really good at my job and then
there's a there's a you be you go deeper
like the roots start growing deep does
that make sense
that does make sense and so here's
here's what I want you the the exercise
not so much 33 year old Caleb like okay
you've got this job you're cyber
security tell us how that feels because
you're gonna have a crummy boss you're
gonna have an idiot that keeps taking
the food out of the fridge or you're
going to be working from home all by
yourself you're gonna be lonely as I'll
get out you may or may not be married
and you may not have two or three kids
running around making your life bananas
and also bringing you more joy that you
know what to do with so how what are you
gonna feel what is this gonna feel like
it's gonna feel really interesting
because and very I'm very passionate
about those things because cyber
security in and of itself is just
something that I've always had a passion
for defending and helping companies to
overcome their security risk and stuff
like that I don't know if that's so yeah
so you're gonna find Peace by reaching
out for like helping a company solve
some of their problems
exactly right yes sir and that piece is
going to override when you have an
employee I mean a a company that doesn't
pay you when you've got deadlines that
you got to meet and you got to miss
Christmas Eve because you're working
like those all those things are going to
come and they're going to be frustrating
but it's gonna be worth it because
you're working towards a purpose right
you're you're working to
help somebody else solve their problem
and that brings you peace and joy right
exactly right I think I understand
exactly what you're trying to say find
the thing that makes it worth all the
pain there you go
um
so much for the help I really appreciate
it yeah of course thanks for calling
gosh that's oh that's powerful and
that's John you hit the nail on the head
that was good so
yeah I don't know I I here's all I know
I I know I chased titles and I chased
money and I chased credentials and I
chase little fancy plaques
and you've heard me say this a million
times but every time I get a plaque
every time I'd get a raise I went with
me
I wasn't okay with me and it wasn't
until I almost melted the whole thing
down that I realized uh I gotta be okay
with me and then I'm free to move about
the country right then you're free to
whatever job comes that's fine right
well in in almost any job there's gonna
be challenges a hundred percent of jobs
gonna be challenges yeah that's just
part of it but if you're okay yeah then
you can deal with them that's right
we'll be right back this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show our
scripture of the day is John 10 10. the
thief comes only to steal and kill and
destroy I came so that you would have
life and have it abundantly
our quote comes from Maya Angelou my
mission in life is not merely to survive
but to thrive and to do so with some
passion some compassion some humor and
some style I love that get it girl all
right Hey listen if you haven't heard
Christina this is pretty rad on Tuesday
we announced the marriage and money the
money and marriage event is back with me
and Rachel Cruz and a whole gang it's
going to be even wilder than ever before
and this time it's going to be a whole
weekend so join Rachel Cruz and me right
here in Nashville for money and marriage
getaway in October that will have you
and yours and your spouse feeling more
aligned and connected than ever before
the money and marriage getaway is
designed for you and your spouse to
disconnect from everyday life a focus on
marriage listen all across the country
I'm hearing over and over and over lots
of couples who actually love each other
have become roommates they've become
co-managers of their house they have
lost sexual intimacy like it's the whole
thing's just a mess this weekend long
event is for you you're going to get a
fun date night experience time set aside
to reflect and grow together and plenty
of encouragement and ideas from Rachel
Cruz and me that will help the two of
you stay on the same page about money
and your future now listen
um there is platinum level seats that
are almost already sold out we announced
this on Tuesday and it's almost already
all gone get on there right now it's a
three-day event ticket prices start at
6.99 now listen on Tuesday I was like
man that's expensive come to find out
marriage Retreats are a billion dollars
this is the deal of a lifetime I had no
idea
um my wife's like yeah maybe if you took
me on a marriage Retreat once in a while
but listen 6.99 three-day event
um go to ramseysolutions.com events to
reserve your spots ramseysolution.com
events if you screwed up Valentine's Day
the week's not over this is your shot go
to ramseysolutions.com events get money
marriage tickets for you and your spouse
and
maybe she'll forgive you
that's so good that's going to be such
an awesome event all right I wanted to
hit on this we're coming up on the
February 28th Supreme Court decision or
I guess trial for the student loan
forgiveness program and so you can
already kind of feel the tension Rising
you can feel all the media Outlets
starting to talk about it and people are
you're seeing all these articles about
anxiety around student loans and people
being confused and not knowing what's
going to happen and I came across one
article that was really interesting I
wanted to talk to you about it and it
says that majority of student loan
borrowers link mental health issues to
their debt and like that is huge and
especially right now with all of this
limbo I can't even imagine like what
that's got to feel like to be sitting on
top of all the stuff and just not
knowing what's going to happen next so
this article says most student loan
borrowers will struggle to pay their
loan debts and more than half say the
amount of debt they owe is putting a
strain on their mental health a survey
from the online education program elvtr
found that 40 that 54 percent of student
loan borrowers experience mental health
challenges due to the amount of debt
they owe 56 percent of those whose
mental health is affected by students
loans say they've experienced anxiety
while about a third said that they
suffered from depression because of
student loans the survey also found that
student borrowers are putting off major
life events due to debt including
starting a family purchasing a home and
traveling yes it's uh it's a mess it's
an absolute mess and when I think about
the phrase mental health I got I got all
kind of issues with all kind of phrases
but I think about mental health I think
of a couple of different Avenues one is
autonomy do I have say in my life do I
have say in what happens tomorrow and
what comes next do I have some decision
Pat making power in my life
and if I owe a hundred thousand dollars
to the government or to some
um student loan provider I don't they
are deciding where I work they're
deciding what jobs I I take or don't
take they're deciding where I live
um they're Desi deciding whether I start
that small business not me and so
linking back yeah that's going to cause
your body to sound some alarms you're
not running the show somebody else is
running your life right
um if I think about
um the the one of my famous
psychologists who I just love Irvine in
existential psychology this idea this
death anxiety like there's an end coming
if you have been a stu someone paying
back student loans over the last three
or four or five years and this constant
well maybe well maybe I don't know maybe
maybe and this looming thing coming at
you and if you owe 50 or 60 or 75 grand
we've been telling you for years for the
last couple years pay it off while
there's no interest pay it off while
they keep punting but millions and
millions have not
they know that if this thing gets struck
down
that they're going to be faced with a 75
or 80 000 Bill and that just that sense
of foreboding you know that's that's
mental health right I mean that's gonna
that's gonna bury you in a day or it's
gonna just constantly keep the back of
your mind churning all day every day
um if you want to get married if you
want to start a family if you want to
buy a house and you can't because you've
got this this 200 000 chain around your
neck right all of those things play into
this sense of am I safe do I have am I
connected to people and do I have
autonomy and student loans in many cases
take all of those all three of those
things away from you so I'm talking all
these I've been you know you know taught
this for months a month and then just
literally last night I talked to
somebody who was like you know I want to
pay off my debt we had an FPU class and
somebody's like I want to pay off my
debt but the decision on student loan
forgiveness is coming up so should I
just wait should I hold off and I think
that we're in this season where
everybody kind of feels like they're in
the holding pattern right they're
they're like it's so close but yet it's
so far away like you said so what would
you say to the person who is feeling
anxiety and feeling depression how do
they ride out this next few months of
complete uncertainty
I I mean this sounds so cliche at this
point but really you gotta sit down and
decide what you can control and what you
can't and I made the decision at my if
me and my wife did both of us grew up
with not a lot of money and we also
didn't have any unders like our parents
didn't have insights into how student
loans work you just signed that paper
and you got to go to college
and then both of us went to grad school
and then both of us went to kept going
to grad school and so we both I mean we
ended up with a combined six figures of
student loan debt a lot so you've been
there you literally felt those feelings
I couldn't breathe who walked around my
house and my wife's asleep has no idea
how bad things are because I'm keeping
it from her I mean was that linked to
your mental health oh my gosh yes it was
the first time in my life I felt
um I'm not in control of what happens
next and it was paralyzing yeah and I
didn't have this I didn't I mean I was
dishonest with my wife I didn't tell her
how bad it was all it was it was it was
catastrophic but I made the choice at
the end of the day it was an Integrity
issue for me I told somebody whoever
this this faceless nameless somebody is
if you give me money to go to college
I'll pay you back and I signed my name
on that paper I was 18 years old I
didn't know what I was saying but I
signed my name and so it was a big deal
to me to work I mean we worked three or
four jobs like I said we sold our house
moved into an apartment in a residence
hall we figured it out out we drove yeah
we're still driving oh like right we're
we've made sacrifice after sacrifice
after sacrifice far beyond my salary we
were making more money than the life we
were living because we were still paying
stuff back but
it's for me it's provided a great deal
of
um
peace because I I told you I'd pay you
back and I paid you back so okay you're
in that moment where it's like you're
struggling with anxiety linked to
student loans and then obviously
something clicked and y'all got the it's
a tiny tiny step towards a solution not
waiting for some maybe dragon or some
maybe Angel to swoop in and solve my
problem because it's just not and if you
look at all the fine print it continues
to like the the the sign off continues
to reduce right it's like well I'm gonna
wipe all your student loans away then
maybe 25 000 then maybe 10 000 for a
very select few borrowers and maybe in
some like some of my buddies who are
Professor like they got a letter in the
mail you have no more loans like it just
went away that was awesome and I've got
others who are just waiting and waiting
and waiting and waiting and waiting I I
just made the choice in our home I can't
continue to live with this existential
anxiety like this is waiting I'm gonna
start taking action and I think that's
so big we've been saying it throughout
this whole debacle of
pause being extended and being extended
and being you've got to control what you
can control and right now I think this
next season is going to be kind of wild
and people need to buckle up and get
ready for a lot of back and forth with
the government and student loan
forgiveness a lot of confusion and kind
of feeling like chaos but look at your
situation look at your finances and what
can you control start working to pay
these off even if it feels I am crazy
and you're waiting just take control and
start tackling these now all right that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books thanks to Austin Ben James Zach
and Andrew in the booth and to you
America for listening we'll be back soon
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Christina Ellis if you love the
show and want to dive deeper on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]